allez bon on va parler des produits les
plus consommés par les Français en 2023
qui sont considérés comme de la
malbouffe Ludovic torau l'excellent
médecin va tirer la sonnette d'alarme
donc faites attention si vous êtes à
côté ça va sonner c'est parti regarde
les chewingum font leur retour dans nos
paniers de course jusqu'à ce classé
numéro 3 des produits dont les ventes
ont le plus augmenté cette année en tête
du palmarès les produits à base de
volaille comme les nugets sous les
cordons bleus plat préparés nouille
instantané ces produits faciles à
cuisiner était plébiscité cette année on
sent des Français qui malgré toutes les
contraintes et malgré la hausse des prix
et le budget serré cherche quand même
des petits plaisirs du quotidien des
petits plaisirs immédiats donc mais
attention tout de même ils sont souvent
plus chers que les produits bruts et
moins bon pour la santé Ludovic cor
excellent excellent Ludovic qui m'avait
bien manqué j'adore quand il vientou ce
que j'aime bien ce que c'est ça que
j'aime bien c'est des mecs ils disent
les choses tu vois il a de la poigne on
l'écoute quand il parle c'est pas comme
certains d'entre
vous son quels sont c'est quoi les PIR
aliments en terme de malbouffe les trucs
vraiment c'est les trucs vraiment
rédiibitoires les aliments qui sont
réhbitoires c'est ce qu' on beaucoup de
sel etou
graisse ce M B oui c'est tout ce qu'on
mange rapidement et quelque part il
coûte pas le plus cher ah ça il y a deux
problématiques c'est en effet parce que
c'est bien gentil manger C fruits et
légumes par jour mais commentpay ah
c'est ça le prix aujourd'hui des fruits
et des légumes franchement voilà all au
marché la semaine dernière le CL
Clémentine all au marché combienbien à
[Rires]
combien TR balles ouais TR balles le
clon de clémentineépoque clémentine
VI tout ça tout ça pour dire en
introduction écoutez bien ça apportant
les chiffres que je vais vous dire si je
peux me permettre tu m'écoutes plus bien
sû je t'écoute Ludo Ludo il y a 14
millions d'hypertendus traités en France
ouais il y a 7 millions de personnes qui
prendent un traitement pour le
cholestérol m il y a 4,5 million qui
prennent un traitement pour le diabète
ah ouais il y a chaque année 1 million
d'hypertendus en plus dans notre pays il
y a bientôt 5 on avit un hypertendu à
côté de nous bah je pense que de toute
façon on est beaucoup ici to tu es
stressé mais ça ça augmente ça augmente
ça augmente pour le stress et puis la
nourriture le sel le manque d'activité
et tout ça et surtout il y a bientôt 50
% en France d'adultes qui sont en excès
de poids et en obésité ah ouais en 50 %
et le et on a 15 % d'obèse aujourd'hui
ça a doublé en 20 ans donc quand on
parle de malbouffe en fait on parle
surtout de la santé publique comme
toujours et là je peux vous dire qu'en
terme de santé publique on a pris cher
enendre on recommence on l' entendu ou
pas du tout qui discute vous entendu
mais aè le sel le sel c'est dramatique
mais tout est Dr toute façon tout ce qui
peut aiguiser votre appétit et qui vous
rend heureux vous allez le manger c'est
vrai ah ou bah le sel c'est bon quand
quand vous commencez un paquet de chips
vous le finissezouis
quand vous un paquet de gâteau vous le
finissez et il rajoute en plus dans tous
ces gâteaux des choses qui vous excite
un peu plus le gustatif donc vous
n'arrêtez pas vous n'arrêtez pas vous
arrêtez au bout de trois plaquettes de
chocolat TR truc donc si vous voulez
dans une problématique où aujourd'hui
les gens sont stressés et c'est vrai que
manger ça déstresse bien sûr pourquoi
d'ailleurs pourquoi alors pour plusieurs
raisons dis-moi tu es venu BFM TV pour
question raison c'est pas de question
pour deux raisons alors je vais le dire
qu vous BB ou excusez-moi quand vous
étiez bébé pour beaucoup d'entre vous
vous avez tété ah ouis et le lait en
fait il est très riche en graisse et en
sucre donc quand vous avez un peu la
tête dans le sac et ben vous allez têter
c'estàd vous allez prendre beaucoup de
graisse et beaucoup des aliments doudou
quoi dans le sac c'est la prière ch
expliation deuxième chose je savais pas
tu vois tu te rappelles pas quand tu as
tété si cétait sucré ou salé quand j'ai
tété ouais quand tu as
tété je me rappelle plus moi moi je non
mais vas-y voilà donc tout ça pour dire
tout ça pour dire aujourd'hui quand on
est énervé stressé alors déjà quand le
ventre est plein et ben vous dormez
parce qu'en fait votre sang va va faire
digérer donc vous allez moin dans le
cerveau donc quand vous mangez beaucoup
vous allez faire la sieste donc c'est un
moyen aussi de se calmer c'est un
anxiolitique la nourriture quand vous en
prenez un certain niveau ça c'est une
chose et surtout c'est le plaisir le
sucre donne du plaisir le chocolat donne
du plaisir j'adore le chocolat moi bah
oui mais parce que tu as envie d'avoir
du plaisir ouais je sais pas
peut-être un kiffeur oui c'est un
kiffeur toute façon tout ce qui est B
qui excite c'est une drogue en fait on
va parler clairement la nourriture
aujourd'hui ils ont compris ceux qui
fond la nourriture c'est que plus ils
vont vous exciter plus ils vont vous
rendre dépendants et voilà c'est tout
mais pourquoi on est attiré que par la
malbouffe parce qu'il y a du sucre a
dans d'autres produits la graisse aussi
on veut manger que des trucs mauvais
pour nous bah parce que la malbouffe si
tu veux quand on dit malbouffe c'est
tout ce qui nuit à ton organisme donc
c'est ce que je viens de dire
sel tout ce qu' avec et on est attiré
parce que tout simplement d'abord c'est
rapide à faire bien malbou c'est souvent
rapide parce que bon on fait une
caricature sur McDo et tout ce que vous
voulez d'accord si vous en prenez un par
semaine ça pose pas de problème mais aux
États-Unis c'était tous les jours c'est
les gens se tapaient et vous les voyez
l'obésité bah c'est ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui en fait tout ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis généralement en mal
arrive dans notre pays parce qu'on on
sait pas tirer les leçons mais en terme
de prévention on a beau dire ce qu'on
veut il y a rien qui existe hein parce
que à dire les gens acheter ça alors
qu'ils ont pas d'argent alors qu'on
s'est pris 12 % d'augmentation sur les
prod alimentaires aussi bien les bons
que les mauvais voilà et plutôt les bons
ont plus augmentés que les mauvais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est la
problématique aujourd'hui donc et et le
problème c'estes gens vont être de plus
en plus malades puisquon augmente nos
hypertendus chaque année et ben comme il
y a plus de médecin et comme il y a plus
de médicaments et ben on va voir ce qui
va se passer il est grand temps si vous
voulez qu' des bonnes nouvelles
sinon je comprends ah bah là qu'est-ce
que vous mangez vous ici tiens voilà
vous mangez quoi vous moi moi je mange
beaucoup de frites de frites
moule j'adore
çaesprit a raison il y a des antioxyants
merci Docteur merci
Docteur non non mais vous avez vous avez
des problèmes ou pas du tout non pas
trop non un peu de circulation problème
de circulation dans les jambes ou un peu
docteurcord ah oui vois ça ah oui
comment ça vous voyz j' MOS j'en ai
moins
continuer la circulation il a raison les
hypertendus je sais pas à partir je sais
pas quel âge vous avez 62 82 64 j'ai
deux traitements antiypertenseurs vous
en avez peut-être et et vous en aurez
tous parce qu'il y a 1 million chaque
année 1 million 2 d'ti hypertendus qui
sont découverts il faut trit parce que
une fois que tu es hyper tendu après
c'est toutes les pathologies cardiaques
les tout ce qui va avec quoi hyper tendu
comme un string
quoi tu manges bien toi moi je mange pas
de viande ah oua j'aime pas totalement
ça je mange beaucoup de poulet au dedin
de trucs comme ça et du riz le riz
j'adoreors bien c'est bien le riz ou pas
s c'est bien c'est pas en fait il faut
pas trop changer les aliments la
problématique de ce trans ouais faut pas
les transformer c'est faut pas souvent
les plats que vous achetez tout près ils
sont hyper transformer parce qu'on
rajoute plein de choses pour mettre un
goût nouveau et pour vous rendre addicte
à cel Ludovic on a l'impression que tout
ce qui est bon est mauvais ouais ouais
je suis d'accord non parce que vous
pouvez faire des plats mais il faut du
temps la problématique aujourd'hui on
est tellement pressé qu'est-ce que vous
allez passer 2 heures à la cuisine bah
non je crois pas donc quand on peut plus
faire 2 he à la cuisine parce qu'on a 2
heures de route à faire parce que si
parce qu'on est stressé bah on va aller
au plus rapide tout simplement ou
d'accord vous mangez vous vous mangez
bien vous moi non bah moi je suis pas si
sûr parce que déjà je mange au moins 800
g de rest ensemble vous mangez bien
ouais j'ai pris la viande moi à chaque
fois je mange pense que je mange trop de
viande est-ce que c'est bon de manger
trop de viande j'ai un doute et je mange
au moins 10 œufs par jour ah bon 10 œufs
en fait j'ai une obsession
protéine dans le micro pouro tout ce qui
est en excès est mauvais tout ce qui est
en excès est mauvais m c'estàd que siil
avait tu manges beaucoup de protéines il
faut prendre aussi des graisses et des
sucres hein non il peut continuer il a
pas de limite sur la moule ça c'est
clair les œufs c'est pas du cholestérol
les œufs c'est pas du cholestérol et tu
manges pas que le blanc tu manges pas
que le blanc de de l'œuf j'en enlève
quelquesuns sur les 10 je vais en
laisser que C B oui quand même oua
maintenant s'il a du colosérum mais d'un
l'autre côté il fait du sport c'estd que
le problème qu'on a c'est qu'on est de
plus en plus sédentaire donc ce que vous
prenez en plus par rapport aux personnes
nos aïux c'est qu'on on a moins
d'activité physique donc vous on est une
machine on est une voiture au lieu de
rouler à 120 on roule à 80 oua et on
souvit avec une essence qui est pas
bonne donc par la voiture elle va casser
cl ah ouais il a raison vous madame POS
oui moi j'ai la flemme de me faire
manger donc je mange qu'une fois par
jour ah oui et ouais et c'est tous les
jours poulet poulet poulet parce que les
autres viandes ça me dégoûte manger du
poulet oui ah ouais mais c'est pas assez
de
manger les de viandes tout ce qui est
rouge tu manges que ça per pas de pas
d'accompagnement pas de si un poulet ça
comm non mais c'est c'est pas c'est bien
de manger une fois par jour non on est
fait on estement on est fait depuis tout
le temps et puis donc a le faisait il
faut surtout se remettre en arrière
c'est trois fois par jour bien sûr c'est
matin d'ailleurs on dit les anglosaxons
ils mettent le repas principal le matin
vous
et nous on problétique qu'vent le
principal le soir alors qu' a pas
d'activitéprs qu' consme que donc ça
réserve que je veux dire c'est qu'il
faut manger au moment où vous allez
consommer j'ai la solution elle se
réveille à 16h elle m'a dit ah voilà
c'est un indice apparemment toutes
toutes les personnes qui sont là-bas 16h
c'est la place toutes les meufs làb se
réveill ça commence à 19h donc je
parlais pas que de vous Kelly aussi se
réveille Kell c'est midi m 13h je crois
16h c'est ch à 16h vous couchez à quelle
heure très tard 7h vous faites quoi la
nuit 8 9h à ça 8 9h du matin du matin ah
ou vous faites quoienvers non même pas
je suis à la maison vous faites quoi
mais je suis habitué à à pas dormir la
nu vous êes vous êtes sur TikTok sur
inst ouais mais vous savez c'est c'est
génétique he il y a des gens qui sont
faits pour vivre la nuit a des gens qui
sont faits pour la journée dans les
gênes ah c'est vrai ouais
ouais c'est
vrai on a un cycle enfit vous vous avez
trouvé un autre slic comme les comme les
soignants qui soignent qui soignent la
nuit mais le CC naturel c'est quand la
nuit tombe
l'homme suit la nature et doit aussi
tomber maintenant je vous critique pas
c'est une façon de vivre que vous avez
et vous avez trouvé un équilibre mais
néanmoins tous ceux qui travaillent la
nuit le jour où ils arrêtent de
travailler ça devient très compliqué
parce qu'ils ont du mal à retrouver un
rythme norm alors la malbouffe touche la
santé mentale ou par que trop sucré ou
trop grass ça peut développer l'anxiété
une dépression même la maladie
d'alzheimerou mais alors vous avez
raison sur le côté un peu psychologique
pourquoi parce que c'est pas un hasard
si si notre pays il y a autant de
personnes qui sont en surcharge
pondérale et en obésité on est un pays
où très anxiogène on est les plus grands
consommateurs d'anxiolitique d'accord
les plus grands consommateurs de
cannabis numéro 1 en Europe et c'est pas
un hasard ça veut dire tout simplement
on a besoin de se calmer et comment on
se calme soit avec les médicaments soit
avec la nourriture soit avec ces chosesl
c'est clair il y a trop d'agressivité
dans notre pays enfin c'est pas pour
faire de la politique mais c'est trop
tendu chez nous en ce moment et on
essaie de trouver des moyens pour se
calmer et pour un peu sortir de tout ça
et c'est toujour les choses qui sont
mauvais pour le corps c'est bien dans
l'immédiat mais ça vous rend
complètement addicte à ce que vous
prenez que ça soit de la nourriture du
cannabis ou tout ce qu'il y a d'autre la
balbouff abîme les cheveux la peau et
les ongles mais tout ce qui est maais
tout ce que vous avez en excès va vous
va vous abîmer le corps et c'est comme
une voiture elle a besoin de d' essence
bien spéciale si vous changez cette
essence le corps va pas supporter si
vous avez trop de cholestérol ça va pas
ça va boucher vos artères vous ferez un
vis tout ce qui est en excès sans
activité physique va vous nuire parce
que vous consomz pas vot olér une
voiture le cor c'est une voiture c'est
une voiture c'est c'est que de la
mécanique donc mettez de la bonne
essence dans la mécanique faites tourner
votre voiture sinon vous savez bien que
si vous la faites pas tourner elle va
pas démarrer c'est très logique he c'est
pas compliqué le corps humain le corps
c'est une chignnole quoi c'est ça c'est
quoi c'est une chignol mais oui mais oui
on peut changer les pneus de temps en
temps changer des choses mais arrivriver
à un moment tu changes rien ah ouais oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais moi moi
par exemple j'ai une technique vous par
il t'a vu
ça mais justement ou pour être en forme
ici je mange pas de la
journéeé et un peu de sucre voilà ça
c'est bien par la guule non mais sinon
les gens dorment regardez mes collègues
voilà Rais ouais mais attention parce
que c'est comme si comme le corps c'est
une voiture c'est comme si on mettait
pas d'essence dans la voiture cor c'est
une voiture du tout tu en tension comme
café et sucre c'est bien ouais mais
après si tu es trop en tension tu dans
tous les sens FA calme
serein voilà non mais ça ça c'est ton
truc je comprends complètement mais
revenons c'est pas méchant l'homme
normal exactement tu pas normal manger
une fois se taper du café toute la
journée voà c'est un peu voilà peutêtre
que tu conduis une voiture de sport
d'accord mais voilà moi je te parle
d'une voiture normale qui roule et qui
respecte la vitesse et donc voilà un
problème de PET d'échappement maintenant
merci merci merci Ludovic merci en tout
cas alors attendez il y a le classement
des aliments les plus consommés
ah ah en 1 c'est les produits élaborés à
base de
volaille vola
ensuite aliments autres animaux tout ça
boisson énergétique et boisson chaude
prête à boire
benim attention à ça je bois pas ça moi
si si tu bois du beaucoup de soda ah
c'est fini ça elle a tout arrêté tout
arrêé depis 2 ans c'est pas vrai vous la
connaissez pas si bien que ça une
boisson soda non SP ou estod swing gum
plat cuisiné déshydraté les Nou chinoise
attention à ça les
quiches on parle de
toi tarte salée tarte les barres
céréalièr pâte fraîche et fromage fondu
et les chips les chips c'est
catastrophique ou les chips c'est le
pire chips mais toute façon dès quand tu
manges des chips moi je peux pas manger
des chips pour M chips tu es pas bien
non mais déjà tu sens que tu sens que
c'est pas bon pour ton corps il vaut
mieux manger des chips ou des frites des
cul frit les frites c'est évident parce
que au moins quelque chose là tu asun
petit coup de patate avec plein de sel
prendose les chips c'est catastrophique
mais pourquoi le poulet poulet voilà
aujourd'hui il y a un vrai quand vous
allez dans les rayons le poulet
disparaît parce que c'est la viande la
protéine la MO vous pouvez plus vous
acheter de filets de Poul c'est 10 ball
ass RA la vi rouge
ça ce weekend j'ai acheté de filets de
Poul pour
78 V car de
réduction non mais c'est la moins chre
paretch vous êtes allé Intermarché
ah ouais deux blancs de poulet 780 il
faisait combien c'est trop cher trop
cher 7 non c'est plus cher ça dépend
attendez mais ça dépend quel poulet vous
prenez soit vous prenez du poulet élevé
en plein air qui gambade soit celui qui
est comme ça tout ratata ils sont 200
dans le truc et le prix est complètement
différ 470 les deux de
che et je suis allé après chez Ed c'est
5 ou
si à 5 10 de ça dépend où tu
supermarch ou dis bon c'est bon on va
pas parler poulet
2h merci merci vous vous l'inviterz dans
votre émission vous l'avez Ludovic mais
oui je l'adore Ludovic vous êtes
excellent je
l'adore elle m'a mis la honte parce
qu'elle me dit Ludovic est-ce que tu
peux rester parce qu'on va parler la
libido oui je dis donc moi je dis
médicalement je vais pouvoir d'ailleurs
dire vous annoncer qu'à partir de 30 ans
vous perdez 1 % de votre testostérone
prépar oui mais mais tu pas là pour en
parler mais non d'accord par sauf que tu
m'as dit de sortir mais c'est pas moi
qui
S et moi j'ai plein de messes alors
docteur onut pas parler de sbido j'ai
pris très
cher il
dis
cherch cor moi ce que je reti j'ai
l'impression vraim c'est quoi une
mécanique c'est une voiture
fragile je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
on dit qu'il y a une personne sur
5 non mais c'est non mais c'est a une
personne sur 5 qui fait quoi qui meurt
d'une malnutrition de la malbouffe dans
le monde voit c'est une vraie voiture et
je vous conseille de contrôler tout et
de mettre surtout un bon carburant et
vous durrez longtemps faites la tourner
révisezla faites attention à elle faites
la coucher tôt ah mais c'est ça c'est
c'est une chignle merci merci merci
Ludovic mais c'est vrai il a raison
désolé il a raison je suis désolé c'est
une chignle une VO c'est une chignole un
corps un corps